well you've perhaps seen this video
circulating over the past several days
it's not unlike the sorts of videos
we've seen with increasing and tragic
regularity recently in this case it's a
girl named Casey Miller who's now 21
years old began the process of gender
transition when she was 16 years old so
she now like so many others before her
and so many millions more to come after
her deeply regrets what was done to her
and I will not say that she regrets what
she did because this is not something
that she did she didn't decide to
uh aggressively indoctrinate herself
into a cult when she was at an
impressionable young age she didn't
choose to live in a society that's lost
its grip on reality all of that was
inflicted on her she is a victim and now
here she is
yeah um so I got out of my haircut
um because my hair was driving me nuts
and I shaved it because I'm tired of
watching my hair thin out and it's less
distressing if I shave it so when I talk
about being too far gone not I don't
really know what else to call it
um this is what I mean this is how deep
my voice is
um it's gotten deeper over time and it's
settled
um this is what I mean by hair loss and
it just keeps getting worse it keeps
thinning it keeps receding backwards
um
you know and I'm not exactly sure that's
coming back
um those are the main things when I talk
about being androgenized
um to a point of no return
um I really don't see those being
fixable
so that's when I talk about
you know just kind of staying how I am
regardless of how I feel
um that's why just because I I don't
really see me personally being able to
come back from what's happened so far so
I hope that's a little explanatory
um just to kind of give a little bit
more of a
um like kind of the let me reward that
just to kind of you know
talk about like give more awareness to
the situation
um
kind of so you can see where I'm at
words are not working well with me right
now I'm just gonna cut this off
there you go
you know this this is what happens when
you give a woman testosterone this for
five years this is what happens
essentially so
you know that's it stay safe
so that's the reality that she is uh
trapped in and although she can live a
meaningful life obviously in a
fulfilling life the truth is that much
of what was done to her cannot be
reversed and she was convinced that 16
that she wanted something and
now she has to live with what the 16
year old version of herself thought she
wanted forever
as we can see in the video she's losing
her hair she has a receding hairline at
the age of 21.
a very common side effect of hormone
treatment for gender confused girls you
have to remember that girls are are um
not meant to have these levels of
testosterone in their systems their
bodies are not built for that the result
is oftentimes rapid hair loss not to
mention in many cases uh you know weight
gain acne those those are and those are
only the the relatively surface level
problems
but even the seemingly cosmetic side
effects are important because girls who
transition
all of them
are trying to turn themselves into
something that is obviously a fantasy
it's not real so they can never actually
be males they have some they have some
kind of vision of the kind of
man the kind of male they think they can
become
but that vision isn't real and it will
never be real
the same goes in the reverse for boys
who try to transition in the other
direction these girls because they're
confused and they've been brainwashed
and indoctrinated
they believe that in some ineffable
mysterious way
their fundamental Essence is that of a
man they're uh you know a boy trapped in
a girl's body as it's often expressed
and yet none of them imagine that this
boy trapped inside them is is overweight
with a receding hairline or chronic acne
and I don't say that obviously to make a
joke out of it at all there's nothing
remotely funny about this my point is
that is that is that every single
gender-confused person male or female
is grasping for some Vision some fantasy
of themselves that isn't real and will
never be real
the girl rejects her femaleness in favor
of her fantasy of maleness but she'll
never achieve it she'll never she'll
never arrive at her destination she'll
be stuck instead in some sort of
hellish limbo having lost her femininity
but not having replaced it with anything
like masculinity
certainly not the sort of masculinity
that she had imagined in her head
she'll be stuck with some of the worst
aspects of of being a male you know
thinning hair for example
but she's not going to actually be a
male
one of the cruelest ironies is that a
transitioned quote unquote female
will forever sound something like an
adolescent boy going through puberty but
we'll have the thinning hair and and
sometimes the beer gut of a 40 year old
and yet still will not look like an
adolescent boy or a 40 Old Man
this is what's being sold to teenage
girls
it's a ticket to the worst of all
possible worlds that's what's being sold
to them only they're not being told that
that's what's being sold to them
they're being sold on the surface of
fantasy and then this is what they get
you know the left is losing their faith
but we are not and a core part of that
faith is prayer I talk a lot about
stressful things all day and you might
feel a little bit overwhelmed with where
the country is going I know that I do
sometimes but I've got good news hallow
could help you find some peace and hope
rooted not in the government or
institutions but in God hallow has over
5 000 audio guided prayers meditations
and peaceful Christian music including
the Bible in a year with father Mike
Schmitz minute meditations prayers for
kids and much more hallow helps helps
you build a daily routine and a habit of
prayer helps me to stay to pray to
meditate to stay calm as calm as I can
be anyway and also to sleep better it's
a huge part of my daily routine well you
can get an exclusive three-month trial
of hallow hallow.com Matt Walsh that's
hello.com Matt Walsh reclaim your piece
in this crazy world download hello today
but there's another aspect of the story
that hasn't gotten as much attention
uh the girl
who changes her mind
will not only be stuck with the
irreversible changes inflicted on her
body but to add vicious insult to severe
injury
she will also have to endure the
venomous attacks from trans activists
who will treat her like a traitor
if she decides that she'd rather Embrace
her biological identity than continue
living a lie
so the the comments under Casey's video
and Twitter are overrun with trans
people ruthlessly insulting and mocking
her ruthless
this includes prominent trans activists
with large followings who have sent
their Legions to tear this girl to
shreds
she's already suffering
she's already in a very dark place
obviously
and they're trying to send it right over
the edge
this is someone suffering and their
response is to mock her and belittle her
and express contempt for her
not only that but most of them are still
referring to her as him you know so much
for preferred pronouns they've decided
that she's a man and can never not be a
man no matter what she says about
herself
now I would go through and read you
examples of the sorts of things they're
saying but I think that would be that
would not be very productive and I also
don't really want to amplify these
insults though you can go to her page
and see it for yourself
so this is something to keep in mind
when when you and this is why it's
important because when you hear about
uh the the number of detransitioners and
people who are expressing regret about
their transitions
these are only the people willing to
speak out
in spite of the mockery and threats and
alienation and social ostracization
they'll experience because of how many
more would be going public if not for
their fear of experiencing the exact
same kind of treatment
and also remember this when you hear the
claim
that younger children are only socially
transitioning and that the social
transition uh it's not as serious as a
medical transition
when you hear that claim keep this in
mind oh we only socially transition
five-year-olds they say it's not like
we're performing surgery on them
yes we'll we'll see how long that lasts
because that's they they would like to
go to a point get to a point where
they're performing surgery on
five-year-olds
but regardless the social transition
leads inexorably and inevitably to the
medical transition because once the
child has started down this path it
becomes quickly clear to him that there
will be a severe social penalty for
changing course
so for all the talk of affirmation and
acceptance among left-wing trans
activists it's no surprise that these
are without question the least affirming
and accepting human beings on the face
of the planet
why is that
well simply because they care for
nothing and no one but themselves I mean
they they talk of affirmation but they
don't mean it in a you as a universal
principle
they don't care about you being affirmed
I don't give a damn about you you can go
to hell you can die
the way they're treating this girl as
far as their concerned she can die she
can kill herself I mean some of them are
very very open about that they her vow
her life doesn't matter to them she is
dirt she's scum she's a traitor as far
as they see it
the only sort of affirmation that they
care about or demand
is affirmation of themselves and of
their own life choices that's it it's
all about them individually
as they see it the entire human race
exists purely for this purpose to affirm
them and make them feel better and
nobody has any other purpose on Earth
but that which is why if you don't do
that if you don't affirm then you then
you can die too your life has no meaning
because your only purpose in life is to
affirm them personally it's the only
reason you're here
a d-trans person then is is the greatest
affront of all
because she makes the trans activist
feel bad about his choices
She lays bare the truth behind all the
lies that he tells himself and the world
her decision her life path is a is a
direct attack on him
as he perceives it
because he sees everything as directly
relating to him he cannot conceive of
realities that exist apart from him or
of a universe in which he is not the
center
hyper narcissism is the engine that
drives the trans movement and and
everything else on the left
it's no surprise then to see this
reaction also one of the undying truths
of life and uh it's a cliche but it's
true is that misery loves company
the trans activist is miserable and
unhappy
and he lashes out at anyone who tries to
escape the prison that he has put
himself into
you you are not allowed to leave this
behind and strive for a a more whole and
complete Life One lived in harmony with
your biological nature rather than at
war with it you're not allowed to do
that because he's not doing that
and he wants you to remain trapped
and in despair
same as him
but that also goes back to the
narcissism
and that's what lies at the core
of all of this that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not we'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]